all right welcome everybody
we are here together once again i'm so
glad that you're with me because this is
actually going to be the last
stream for the week because
um because it just is i have a very very
busy next few days and then we have the
debate
next week which is going to be huge i
predict i'm hoping for my biggest stream
ever but you know we don't know
ultimately
i can't control it it will be up to you
will you be here with me
uh next tuesday night i hope that i hope
that you will
donald trump has two events today i'm
just going to be covering the first one
scheduled for 20 minutes from now donald
trump as far as i know left the white
house nearly an hour ago
so more or less on time he should be
running
we are keeping an eye on the fox news
feed we are keeping an eye on the white
house feed
technically the first appearance is not
a campaign
appearance which is why the official
white house channel
carries it although you and i know that
at least colloquially speaking
it is a campaign appearance then 7 p.m
eastern donald trump has an
actual campaign appearance i will not be
streaming that one you will be on your
own for that one or maybe you'll watch
it with like
you know right side broadcasting or
something like that that'll be your call
that'll be your call completely i have
some memes
i have videos i have polling i have
plasma
um i have jessie lee peterson excerpts
people have already been sending them
and and pointing to funny moments from
it so
we we have plenty of things to do but
let me um
before we jump in i you know i might be
better advised to wait a little bit
and to do this when we have more people
um
uh more people watching but i'm just
going to do it now so that then on the
on the replay people will see this right
away i'm getting a lot of emails from
people
with with different perspectives on
what's about to happen to the united
states in the next six weeks or it could
take
could be eight weeks could be ten weeks
we don't really know but the election
isn't five and a half weeks
i'm getting emails from people on the
left basically expressing
anxiety expressing
um concern expressing
a feeling of impotence that you know
what what can we really do it seems like
so many things are just stacked against
logic and reason
um and then i'm also getting emails from
people on the right
and in fact let me see if i can just to
really
to really put some color in it for you
let me see if i can find it
there is this particular color
um i'll give you an exact sense of it i
mean why we're all here together i might
as well illustrate it
more uh i don't want to give you a black
and white version let me give you the
full color it's always better
i'm just looking for this in my
voicemail
uh where is this where where where
is it i don't want to
oh hold on was this an unknown this will
be worth it i
should have had this ready i'm sort of
just riffing right now um
nope it's not this one oh man this is
not uh oh here it is
here it is okay yeah so this is the
other side this is what i'm getting from
the right
a danielle prickles guess what
mittens romney didn't flip we're going
to have a conservative
republican superior supreme court
ha ha you greasy argentine
gaucho sort of laughs on you and
and the the nominee's gonna sail right
on through
and there's nothing you can do about it
now okay
and then that same caller that's not
even the most aggressive one let me
actually show you
here's the other one okay and it in in
all seriousness if there are kids in the
room
do this is not for kids
hey daniel pack girl what are you doing
you idiot you greasy argentinian
we're going to have another
of superior court judge a conservative
republican
and there ain't nothing you democrats
can do and
you and your idol threats we're gonna
we're gonna triumph hey do me a favor
go take a broom handle and stick it up
your [ __ ]
vagina right so
that's pretty aggressive and that's no
joke
but at the end of the day um
[Music]
that gentleman may be right in the sense
that
trump may get another four years fair or
unfair
and i think that it's a really
we um the message i'm trying to sort of
put out there
is it it's sort of it's a message of
stoicism
and it's also a message not to get all
nihilistic but it it's also a message
about
um what can we certainly do in the world
and so you know people who call in and
say david i can't wait to see you cry if
trump wins
on on election night or whatever um you
know
as i've said before from a financial
standpoint
trump winning is good for me i think
it's terrible for the country but it's
good for me i know that the show will be
fine either way
but things are outrageous with trump and
it'll be less boring
in a sense terrible for the country and
i'll be better off so
you know the idea that i'm going to cry
it will be very sad for the country
if donald trump gets another four years
but ultimately all i can do is give you
my perspective
and in the in the long term we're all
dead right and this is where it's all
like
to getting into the the nihilistic
perspective as long as we can feel like
we did everything we could and i've
provided you
either some education insider
entertainment or some combination of the
three
i'm gonna feel okay that i did what i
could do
and i can't control the results i can't
control the fact that there are 63
64 65 million people in this country
who are going to vote for four more
years of trump it's not an indictment of
me or of you ultimately we can only do
what we can do
and if in the end we're all dead anyway
if we can have a community in the
meantime if we can have some fun in the
meantime
if we can pass some time uh together as
a community in the meantime
then then i've sort of done my piece so
you know this idea of
i'm going to cry on election night i'm
fortunate enough to live in
massachusetts
where i am insulated from a lot of the
horrible things that donald trump is
doing i'm fortunate enough
uh that you know i have a business where
when coronavirus hit i wasn't one of the
people that lost my job and all of these
different things so it's
it's really more about the people
calling and telling me oh i can't wait
to see you cry on election night well
if i cried it would be more concerned
for those people
right who are who are not as fortunate
as i am so
that's all we can do that's all we can
do and in the end if we uh
if if we learn something in the meantime
if we become educated in the meantime
what what else what else can we do so
that'll be my perspective and we will we
will of course be together on uh on
election night and see how all of that
goes
all right we are standing by for donald
trump scheduled for the bottom of the
hour
uh i think i'm actually it's all of a
sudden warm in boston i'm just going to
turn on
my air conditioning briefly which i can
control with my phone just to cool
things down a little bit
there we go did anybody hear that kick
on by the way my understanding is the
way my equipment is tuned the air
conditioning it comes off totally silent
on mic um
you didn't hear it okay very good sounds
like things are working beautifully then
didn't hear it's totally silent right i
can barely hear it so i figured that the
mic was not
i was not going to hear it okay very
good um
super chats are coming in let me look at
a couple of these and then i have so
much other stuff for you guys
okay uh chakaseki says david your
interview with jessie lee peterson was
fire i learned i'm a beta male and my
academic degrees are worthless as i have
no common sense
chakaseki also adding presidential
slouch trump was a delight to watch as
his slumping posture connoted both a
sense of emasculation
and a full diaper as protesters booed
okay yeah let's do that i have that
video donald trump today going to visit
ruth bader ginsburg's cat
ginsburg's casket and he was brutally
brutally booed and you'll hear a chant
of vote him out start it's great
you're gonna hear this momentarily
[Applause]
[Applause]
trump later said he couldn't really hear
the protesters
okay so anyway so that's that it was not
a particularly good day for donald trump
uh
at the supreme court today not uh not
very good
um and then now we are waiting for him
in uh in north uh in north charlotte
north carolina
thank you to irie mann and rusty
shacklefart
each cheering 1 000 bits
on twitch where we have a hype train
going also thanks to mark montag
mark is new member number one today at
joinpackman.com
i am flattered by your support mark very
much appreciate it
other super chats coming in alex
arvanitas
says no david don't leave us alone with
him
dereten says if biden wins as your work
evolves consider
streaming in europe to do deep dives and
interviews to flesh out northern europe
social democracy for your audience
listen if trump wins i would love
nothing more
than to hide out in sweden norway
finland denmark and estonia
for a very strong period of time andrew
stewart says how did you keep a straight
face with jessie lee peterson
i'm just so desensitized by him
that it's sort of like i i just don't
really care anymore
i'm going to play a couple clips from
the jlp interview momentarily
wallerismi says 1.01 million subscribers
nice job they say the first million is
the hardest
i look forward to when we can all
discuss things with more nuance and not
just rail against insanity when biden is
in your show will continue i'll still
watch
thank you i appreciate that danny
thompson says i ventured into right side
chat when kaylee spoke earlier i
suggested they wait until november 3rd
to vote
they all know those are the only ones
that will count jam up 11
3 check trolling done all right danny
double dd beat says hi david do the u.s
have an independent branch of the
government or any kind of authority that
will do something about those protests
at the ballots
uh i i am worried that the intimidation
at polling places will be allowed to uh
to happen and uh we've uh we have to
figure we have to figure out what to do
about it
but hopefully there will at least it's
much of it's managed at the county level
interestingly enough
and hopefully that will be uh looked at
by
responsible counties thanks to ireman
and blaze king each cheering a thousand
bits as we move on to a level
three hype train on twitch i appreciate
that very much
amy gray says i don't know how people
can be so attached to a party
and have so much hate for another it
wouldn't matter to me what party a
person was if they are a bad person
well said james montalbano
says huge missed opportunity by not
wearing your data mail shirt on your
interview with jesse lee peterson i know
i know let's look at some clips um so
yesterday i
i previewed this because it had not yet
published
it has now published but let me give you
guys just a couple of moments that
people found
interesting uh i did these yesterday but
we're going to do them again
now oh oh let me address something else
i started getting emails from people
saying david it's really it's really
gross
what you did interviewing a man who's
clearly cognitively handicapped
and i don't know that about jessie lee
peterson and there's a couple different
things here this guy has a show where he
comments on politics so the idea that
the problem is
i'm having him on it's hard to make that
case i didn't just go and look for
someone who's cognitively challenged if
indeed he is and have him on number two
i've also been told that he has a uh a
cleft
palate and thus a speech impediment but
that cognitively there's no evidence
he's actually
limited i'm not a doctor i don't know
the point is
his producer wrote to me and said have
him on i'm not saying he isn't nuts but
i i got emails people saying i was being
ableist
by ridiculing a guy who clearly is not
there
mentally i i don't know that i really
don't and again
he he said he wants to be on this is his
job
okay so let's look at just a couple
clips here
the full interview is on my youtube
channel and you can check it out here's
just a little bit
are you a christian pastor i am yes you
are and what what denomination
non-denominational christian
okay and i remember that your studio in
l.a people may find this interesting
is it also some kind of christian
counseling center
do i remember that correctly where you
counsel young men
yeah but uh not in the studio we have i
have my offices
upstairs and so we we council in
in-house and
by skype or telephone or by phone
whichever is easy for the folks
that's fascinating and so now you're
you're not like a therapist right you're
not a social worker or a psychologist or
anything like that
no just a counselor okay and that that's
in california that's an unregulated
credential right anybody can use that
term
well you have to you have to by the way
i'm not wearing the same shirt yesterday
i wore a black shirt i'm wearing a gray
shirt today
be a minister or a pastor or something
like that and you could do counseling
under the hand in them
of your ministry wow and that insurance
doesn't cover that right
it does it does in california you can go
to a counselor who's just a minister and
it's considered a medical visit 100
so that was a very concerning moment
then we got into policy
and unfortunately it turns out jesse
doesn't know a lot of policy
and when you talk about the job that
trump has done
just to pick something to really dig
into and make this um you know i want to
take the interview seriously and
you know hopefully it won't devolve the
way some of the prior interviews have
let's take economics and taxation for
example
do you like the trump tax plan and if so
what do you like about it
well that's why i like the fact that he
is cut back on taxes and giving more
money to the workers
rather than taking it i like the fact
that he
um has made it easier for small
businesses to get going
even though we have a chinese virus
situation right now so the economy
uh has stopped a little bit but it's
starting to come back
and dude what what's the regulations but
let's pick something
let's pick one thing what has trump done
to make
it easier for businesses to get going by
cutting back on so many rules and
regulations that the democrat had
established
like what what's an example of such a
such a rule i don't have anything
in mind right now yeah but a lot of the
rules of regulation that was preventing
uh
uh small businesses from starting yeah
have been taken away by the great white
hope
what would be but so give me just i
don't i know that there's dozens and
dozens but what's
one such rule that was taken away that
now makes it easier to start a business
nothing come to mind right now it is
there anything that you can remember
even seeing at any time nothing come to
mind
nothing wow that's amazing amazing
yeah so there was that and then we'll
just look at one more clip and
the full interview is out now so you
guys can very easily see the entire
thing and i encourage you to do it
take a look at this absolutely otherwise
it's not going to work
jesse listen
oh my god i'm getting ads on my own
channel hold on a second that's good
though i like that there's ads playing
at least not demonetized
uh i i do want to just ask about one
more thing
our audience may or may not know you're
you're in your 70s
are what are you drinking pomegranate
what are you doing
in order to keep that glow i don't have
any anger in my heart
i only have love which come from god and
when you don't have anger you're not
stressed out you're not worried you're
not
having suicidal thought you're not
comparing yourself to others
you're not trying to be like anyone else
you are yourself
you're in a perfect peaceful place
within yourself
so you're not comparing yourself to
anyone when you don't have
anger that's why you have to overcome
anger if you want perfect peace
what so it's not like you've switched to
turkey bacon or you eat a lot of fruit
or have
kind of some special skin it's just
you're just not an angry guy
no i don't have anger so i'm not under
stress and you don't attribute any of it
to diet
no i do work out you know i exercise i
eat in moderation now but i do it
because
you know i have a self-control
now i don't have to give in to all that
stuff and plus i don't have anger so i'm
not trying to fulfill my
an ego right most people who are out of
control and the way they eat
have sex use pot and drink they have an
ego problem they have an anger problem
that's why we show people how to
overcome that anger
so they can have peace within themselves
then they would do all things in
moderation
wow and are you are you off sex all
together now
i am you are because i'm not only
because i'm not married
if i was married i would not be offset
wow that's a revelation i think the
audience will find compelling that's
very very interesting
um and you think that you're not married
right i am not married
are you obsessed or you haven't said
well i'm very much on sex
there you go so that was an exciting
moment during the interview with jessie
lee peterson
and um yeah so anyway check out i hope
people check out the entire thing it
really really is compelling it's
something else and
um the whole i mean we did that's just a
sampling that's like three or four
minutes but
i found it really entertaining uh to to
watch i
it's so funny i've watched it twice
myself because i find it so entertaining
producer pat told me he watched it twice
because he found it so entertaining
and i'm hearing that from a lot of
people that it has a lot of replay value
for lack of a better term
all right we have 40 seconds left to
complete a level 4 hype train on twitch
let's do it freedom jesus is gifting
subscriptions
uh boy meets mini is cheering
so much is happening on twitch and we
have just 30 seconds within which we
we can do that i say let's do it let's
do it
i also want to say thanks to richard
tyree who is new member number two today
diana hullett is new member number three
and chris wagner is new member number
four on a very special website
join pacman.com
um let me see if i have anything else
for you guys
oh oh oh oh speaking of the jessie lee
peterson interview
um i got this from a viewer
who said they were what let me see if i
can zoom this in properly for you guys
they were watching they
the jesse lee peterson interview which
is from yesterday was
promoted to them as being a year old
and being a video called knitting
patterns
chevron or zigzag a simple spectacular
something
can you imagine what is going on with
that
a video from yesterday of me and jesse
promoted as a year old video about
knitting that's an unusual glitch i've
never experienced that on youtube before
but this was sent to me today um
and so that that's very exciting i know
a lot of people really really like that
so that's that we've gotten that out of
the way
let me see if i have anything else in
terms of memes
um what is this right here oh oh oh oh
this slipped by some of us yesterday but
donald trump seemed to not know
yesterday that you can test for the flu
and test for coronavirus and know which
is which check this out this is weird
i think we're rounding the turn very
much you see what's happening in europe
however they have a
very big spike countries that we thought
were doing well aren't doing well they
had some
very big spikes very a very big surge
months ago we increased our nation's
procurement
of the flu vaccine by 66 percent and we
ask americans to go get their annual flu
shot as early as possible
it's possible i would imagine scott that
the flu can get mixed up with the virus
and
people can think it's the virus when
actually it's another flu season coming
on and
i don't know it's uh i hope they can
keep them separate can they keep them
separate
we hope so i doubt they will i doubt can
they keep them separate guys
he's been talking to us for six months
about coronavirus tests
that's how you figure out if someone has
coronavirus there's a different test for
the flu
this wasn't even rep i did a segment on
it which we'll publish later to youtube
wouldn't that be big news that the
president who's been talking about
testing for months
says hey you know what somebody you
might think they have the flu and they
have coronavirus
or you might think they have coronavirus
and they have the flu do we have any way
to figure out which is which
yes yes those tests you've been talking
about for months that's how we figure
out which is which
it didn't even make headlines it didn't
even make headlines but we talked about
it
we talked about it certainly i know you
know that okay
um now that we are more or less
caught up let me see what else we have
coming in via super chat
this is a perfect time if you're
watching on youtube
to send a super chat okay uh
jamal swift says hi homie hey jamal
great to see you
jamal has been a fixture at these
streams matt chavez says what's your
official what's your honest opinion of
what trumpus will do if trump loses
you've said violence can happen but how
bad do you think it will get i i don't
know because it'll depend on what trump
says
if trump comes out strongly and says it
was rigged it was stolen
they they did me wrong um then i think
there there is a good chance for real
world violence
it's going to depend on trump jen o fire
says i'm in japan husband and military
so we'll be back either way
however i'm worried about my family
that's my fear
i i understand jen michael hawk
says there's a reddit thread about
experiences meeting youtubers
sometimes someone claimed they
approached you in a coffee shop and you
refused a selfie and were aloof
i've never refused a picture with
anybody no so that's not true but i
would love to see if anybody can link me
to that i would love to read that and
see if i can figure out what
people are talking about i have never
refused a picture
with anybody who has asked me for one so
that is uh completely
completely untrue jf
gambi says still working on your coming
to france especially if you need to flee
out of gilead one day
yeah i would love to just go like to
brittany for four months and just hang i
think that would be really good
um c
says what would you think of a law that
says supreme court nominees can't be
approved without bipartisan support
how are you going to pass the law that's
uh that's the real question
oh boy i just lost a lot of these hold
on
um donna williams says the last two
press conferences with kaylee mcnoodle
were more outrageous than usual did you
see them thank you i did not see them i
did not
shauna harris says keep up the good work
david thanks shauna
reuben larson says hi from norway david
you're welcome to guide out here no
problem
very good stephen partney says last poll
for alaska u.s senate race even
43 each this could be an important race
uh due to quirks in u.s electoral
representation
alaska population 731 000 california
population
40 million both have two senators yeah
there are a lot of elements of american
politics that are very undemocratic i
mean the truth is
two senators per state uh is a huge
handout to
low population republican rural states
gerrymandering is a handout to
republicans
the electoral college is a handout to
republicans a lot of people don't
consider that many of the supposed
checks and balances we have
uh aren't really working very well thank
you to
shot x thomas for the twitch prime sub
wotay has subscribed with prime
aronis has subscribed with prime
the swag chef has subscribed with prime
taste has also sent a little cheer a
modest
cheer but appreciated nonetheless also
thanks to andrew deutsch
andrew deutsch is new member number five
on my website
joinpakman.com uh we are
expecting donald trump any moment oh
thanks to safety wipe and the jason mars
as well
uh i appreciate that let me see if we
have any
live feeds that give us a sense of
what's going on
uh oh we do have i'm gonna have to pick
up a little bit of the right side
broadcasting feed
is gonna shoot towards a target you're
gonna have an app on your phone that oh
my god that's toxic
okay we are we are standing by here oh
you know what this is actually this
looks like it's trump's later event the
jacksonville florida event
uh which is which is obviously much much
later we're waiting for trump in
charlotte north carolina
let me see if donald trump maybe has
texted anything with an
update on timing let's take a look
just some propaganda videos
on my way to north carolina that was
four minutes ago oh boy that doesn't
bode well
um all right well we'll
we'll keep an eye on it i think we might
be okay uh it is all scheduled to start
oh right side broadcasting found a
catholic priest i guess that's
good good for them let me see if we have
any other
feeds that might be
i want to see live what's going on live
in charlotte
um trump charlotte
let's see what we've got um
[Music]
the fox news feed let's see who's
actually live right now
thanks to pink poison games me duber the
jason mars and safety wipe for the
subscriptions i appreciate that
oh donald trump has just landed okay
very good oh this is good
we're actually we're actually moderately
on time i just saw video of trump
landing there it is
donald trump landing in charlotte north
carolina for an event so that's going to
get going very very soon
uh all right yes people asking i
am going to be streaming the entire
debate
on tuesday i want you here with me okay
don't watch it on breitbart
don't watch it on the daily wire don't
watch it on fox or cnn watch with me
we're going to be here 8 30 pm eastern
time
on tuesday 8 30 p.m east 5 30 p.m
west we will do a half hour pre-show we
will do the debate
live and if things go well i have a
sense it's going to be a strong stream
if things go well
we are going to open up the phone lines
so powerfully
it's going to make your eardrums bleed
that's how strongly
the phone lines are going to be open on
tuesday
other super chats are coming in rad rai
says what are the chances that trump
will hack voting machines
i i actually i don't think uh hacking
voting machines is going to be the
mechanism
i don't think it's going to be the
mechanism leno sanchez has ever thought
about debating ben shapiro again
got a feeling he knows he would lose
many if not most of the debates against
you
i don't know about that i mean he talks
way faster than me and
and and uh you know has this confident
demeanor
but we've invited him on a number of
times and he doesn't
um he doesn't respond
so doesn't look like he's interested
emily maiden says i'm watching a few
minutes behind the actual
live stream just heard another deepak
fan ventures into right side chat
too funny so do i it's crazy
seth barham says amazing a lot of
amazing stuff
pedro miramon says now that's mentioned
jesse does look challenged
oh boy andre says if trump gets another
four years you should move to germany
and enjoy social democracy why keep
fighting against windmills seems like a
waste of time
i don't know that moving to germany is
that easy but you know i would try to go
somewhere where i either speak the
language or sort of speak the language
so you know the uk spain france
uh brussels is is mostly french-speaking
or at least you know significantly
french-speaking
um so i would probably focus on those
uh i mean a lot of people in germany do
speak english it's true
it's very very true so trump is in
charlotte we're standing by for the
start of this uh
event an event
i guess is what we're calling it
skitoshi nakayobro says i love you
wow that's a beautiful message johann
nielsen says if roe v wade is repealed
can individual states still allow
abortions
yes yes yes yes no it's not a
countrywide ban
it would mean states can ban it if they
want
that's what it would mean nina keitel
says i voted my granny just voted for
her first democrat ever
love it love it
brendan sayer says hey david i want to
know your thoughts on kaylee mckenna's
playboy comment i didn't see it if
somebody tells me what it is
or maybe i can find it let me see if i
can do a twitter search for that
video
uh let's see here maga nanny
playboy let's see what she had to say
ellie and kaylee why does he keep
playing playboy correspondent brian
karam
playboy oh i actually don't know
oh she just dismissed a question asked
by a playboy reporter okay maybe we'll
look at that in a little bit maybe we'll
look at that in a little bit
uh let me make a very powerful
inducement to you
to subscribe on my website at
joinpakman.com
okay when we talk about independent
media
we are not talking about you know cnn
and msnbc and fox news they have money
trees
they just have money's growing on trees
over there we're mostly funded directly
by viewers like you
and the number one such funding source
is website memberships
which you can get at joinpakman.com so
grab one
grab one of these memberships it's
really cheap it's really easy
you get an extra show every day just for
you
and with the discount code above my head
20 20 now
it's embarrassingly cheap it's almost
too
cheap it's immorally cheap it's
sociopathically inexpensive
um and i will say your name on the show
and this blue bar will start to fill up
so as i say many times if you don't like
what i'm doing
get the hell out of here no you can stay
but you don't have to support me
uh whoa jeopardy that was weird um if
you
uh don't value what i'm doing don't
support me if you don't have a couple
bucks
then don't support me but if you're in a
financial position where a couple bucks
is okay
then i would love it if you subscribed
at joinpakman.com
and if you apply the coupon code 2020
now it will be only
two bucks a month or if you pay for the
entire year it'll be a dollar eighty a
month
really really cheap okay really really
cheap stuff
and it keeps the lights on it funds
health care for employees
all of those things that we try to do
here
as normal people living in the world and
trying to be good to other people that's
all that we're doing
oh people are saying the prices are too
low that they need to go up
well don't worry we have we have a
mechanism for that
um if you want to pay more you
absolutely can
uh and in fact it's it's it's almost too
easy to pay more
well what just happened here something
weird just popped up on my screen
let's see here ah there we go okay we're
standing by for donald trump
yeah if if you think the prices are too
cheap you just drag this up and it'll
get it'll get better
okay and you can even switch to yearly
and you can drag up
and you can spend almost as much as you
want almost as much
as much as you want okay donald trump
has arrived in charlotte
and we are standing by for him i do want
to say
a couple of other thank yous harry has
subscribed on twitch
quills has subscribed on twitch my art
is my
arsenal has subscribed on twitch so has
ray ferguson and seton six
seton six i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly other super chats coming in
uh michael pugh says how are you quick
at catching
those bad names oh i miss half of them i
might have just missed one
uh daniel newbauer says can trump force
the electoral college to vote for him
even if he loses since republicans
control the senate
that's the theory outlined in a new
atlantic article and i discussed that on
today's podcast
so uh certainly check that out
danny thompson says my husband works for
a large clinic system here in the twin
cities
our area is out of the high-dose flu
shot for 65 plus and governor walls
has called out the national guard for
pence and ivanka today i've actually
heard that the 65 plus flu shot
availability is a problem in a lot of
places
uh not not just uh where you are i'm a
little worried that no one else is live
yet
let's see what else is happening on
right side broadcasting here
uh they're still going with the catholic
priest okay
a donald trump about to deplane john
hagen says
norm norway welcomes you as a political
refugee
yeah that's uh maybe not as crazy as you
might think
maybe not as crazy as you might think
let me say thanks to dominic
iwanski who's new member number six
today at joinedpakman.com
resell strauss is new member number
seven
karen medina is new member number eight
emma talbot
is new member number nine really
appreciate that thanks very much
donald trump getting ready to de-plane
the orange express
in charlotte north carolina headed to
a healthcare event i i actually think
that the healthcare event might be a bit
of a drive
from uh from the airport but we will see
so far it has not been
rescheduled but we will see yeah like i
don't think this place on the left here
is at the airport so we're gonna have to
see and nobody else is live yet which is
weird
which is weird but we'll figure it out
very soon yeah it looks like trump's
gonna get right into the vehicle there
um okay skillet queso says hasn't he
been to north carolina like four to five
times yes trump's spending a lot of time
in north carolina then on to florida
tonight
and then overnighting at one of his
various uh
golf clubs tonight chaka seki says can
you prepare a bingo board for the
debates do you think he will call biden
sleepy to his face
let's let's actually do that right now
just because we have time
let me get my legal pad um i
i will put together a bingo board
start get start telling me what should
be on the bingo board i will make notes
of some of these and then i will put it
together
so i think um using the term
sleepy joe during the debate should
definitely be on there
uh i mean it's like guaranteed he's
gonna use the term china virus that's
for sure
i think socialism communism
is a good inclusion let me see what else
we've got
um if he said plasma it would be great i
don't know that it'll come up during a
debate
referring to the basement as where joe
biden has been i think that that does
make
sense um
i think you know hinging and swiveling
at the waist
hinge and swivel at waist that likely
will happen
unsolicited ballots that's good
referencing hunter biden i think that
that's very good yeah we've gotta
i'm gonna have to take these down oh uh
take away
guns slash cancel second
amendment i think is good what else do
we have
referring to 1917 flu yeah maybe maybe
1917.
um the sir routine
if he pulled that out during the debate
that would probably be interesting
um hugging the lectern yeah
okay i i mean i guess we could say
appearing to be
on either uppers or downers i think
that's a relevant inclusion
sir routine we have
obama gate slash
uh political crime yep or they spied on
me
i think that's got that's good uh
glitching if he glitched yeah
right elbow twitch some combination yeah
so we'll call that i think that's an
all-in-one
glitch uh right elbow
twitch or slapping the leg audibly
slapping the lectern
now the thing is not all i don't think
there will be lecterns uh oh is it
raining
trump does not do well in the rain
yikes um
impeachment hoax or any kind of hoax
references to a hoax i think makes sense
yeah
um
all right well i think oh perfect phone
call i think perfect phone call would be
funny
perfect phone call yeah all right that
i've got about 25 now
email me others okay email me others
through my website contact form
davidpakman.com donald trump getting
ready to head
to his first event nobody is yet live
but we will track
donald trump on and over to this first
event
wow super chats have just exploded i
looked away for a second and they've
exploded
drunk emma will be watching the debate
with beers in the icebox i love it
ant and sharon will be watching the
debate with me
next tuesday fantastic the dude says
biden better have a couple one-liners
ready to go
absolutely biden had better be prepared
you'd better be prepared
get chappelle to write him a few cracks
at that [ __ ] or something i
i completely agree jake vx1k
says what's the best way to convince
swing voters unsure voters to vote p.s
plasma
i have a segment on tomorrow's show
about the swing voters so let me not
preempt myself
um oh i just lost a bunch because a
bunch came in at once let me scroll up a
little bit
uh where is this
okay glossy gloss says thoughts on
trump's comments about
not leaving office if biden wins i have
a 10 10 minute segment about that
um on my youtube channel publishing in
minutes
so i don't want to do that right now
charlie moreno says well
real talk fact checking will be part of
the actual debate
or will you do it on your live stream
you know it's going to be tough to fact
check live because half the cr half the
audience
wants me to do it and then the other
half says just shut up
so that's gonna be tough uh we'll we'll
have to see uh
maybe we'll take take a poll on that
all right donald trump heading out now
uh in charlotte and heading to
a health care event nobody else yet live
other than right side broadcasting uh
they are in the room
for the healthcare event and they why
does right side broadcasting have a
catholic priest doing doing uh reporting
it's unusual it's very odd
um but okay things are happening and
off goes donald trump look at this
motorcade by the way like what's in that
van what is in that van that is so
crucial to this motorcade
okay ruiji says watch bernie's address
to the nation from earlier today
i will check that out rick moser says
david i found you
years and have been watching ever since
thanks for the content
thank you eric caselli
says why do you think rogan always
comments on joe biden's cognitive
ability but never calls out trump's
obvious flaws in regards to cognition
great question i don't know the answer
to that i don't know the answer to that
neutral music says with trump not openly
willing to accept the election results
how do you picture the january 20th
inauguration festivities going down well
it depends on who wins
i wouldn't be shocked if trump just
didn't go to biden's inauguration if
there was one
i j i would not be even remotely
surprised
thank you to uh oh i have so many people
to thank who signed up on my website
hold on let me do this oh god this is
crazy
um edwin poole is number 10.
joe belanger is number 11.
the collard fox is number 12.
stephanie fultz is number 13. sarah king
is number 14.
raven asher is number 15.
bradley copp is 16. john norris is new
member number 17
michael bandy is number 18 and david
quigley
is new member number 19 at
joinedpakman.com
love it love it and thank you i
believe we have a real shot at getting
to
25 today we could even do 50 which would
be
not unprecedented but it would be
exciting
robert fancy pants motorcycle mcgee
says with 100 argentinian pesos
currently
worth i think that's like 70 cents at
this point it's
bad what's going on in argentina right
now do you plan on doing some sort of
david pakman 2020 year in review with
everything fun that happened including
chess games cukes and zuks
trump coverage the race to 1 million you
know i think that it exceeds our
capacity
uh we have so much that we are working
on
i think it would be up to if somebody in
the audience like people who have done
the different remixes
wants to do something like that we would
probably if it's good we would publish
it to our youtube channel
but um i don't know that it's within our
capacity to do right now
charles moffat says to evap bian venue
or quebec i am welcome in quebec that's
beautiful i would love to go to quebec
deretend
says check out estonia's e-nomad
visa i should check that out i've
actually read about that
um e-nomad estonia
i um i i went to uh
estonia i was there i actually
met a former david pakman show producer
lewis in estonia
and it was fantastic estonia is
launching a new digital nomad visa for
remote workers
allows remote workers to live in estonia
and legally work for their employer or
their own company registered abroad
love it um digital nomads and remote
workers have long faced ambiguity when
when working while they travel often
skirting the law while working while
visiting with a tourist visa as of
august 1
eligible location independent workers
can apply for the chance to come to
estonia
to live for up to a year with peace of
mind that they can legally work
estonia has already transformed the way
a country serves people beyond its
borders through programs such as
e-residency
now with the digital nomad visa estonia
is transforming how people in the world
choose to work
that sounds interesting uh
if you are able to work independent of
location use telecom technology have
active employment elsewhere
provide evidence that your income meets
the minimum threshold
this is fantastic this is fantastic i'm
going to look at that
i think i'm going to look at that very
strongly i think that that is very
interesting
um okay
what else do we have andy hall says
trump arriving at taxpayer
expense to ridicule and slander said
taxpayers
rachel nelson says have you heard about
cdc report for smithfield meat packing
plant edited the day after it was issued
rachel maddow reported on it a day or so
ago i have not but i will look into it
socks nation says i'm new here i was
sent by
kyle kalinski that's great i love that i
don't know if any i don't know what kyle
did to send you here
uh but if somebody can tell me what kyle
did i would love to to read about it
holly flynn is new member number 20.
craig thompson is new member number 21
candy crow is new member number 22
and shelly clark is new member number 23
today
at joinedpakman.com um we
it's weird to see people asking if we
got to 50 000 followers on twitch
because the number
of followers is public but no we are
just 69 wow
69 we are 69 followers short
of 50 000 on twitch
now 68. um
man it's taken us a while to get to that
50k
isn't that sad um
let's just do it guys let's just get to
the 50 000 on twitch and be done with it
and move on
to uh you know a more powerful number
a six digit number ideally yeah 68
68 followers to go
um 67 okay we may be able to do it we
may be able to do it very nice
all right other super chats that are
coming in anything that's on your mind
let me know via super chat
uh brinstar says move to canada
vancouver is not cold it's beautiful
here when it's not raining and we
consider biden and harris center right
we got health care
fantastic um
remy lebro says love the show d i reply
to your tweet with my take on the scotus
picking
the president are you still taking calls
for the week can't afford
soup super okay we took calls for the
week already
we already took calls for the week ricky
bankemper says david sloot maker pacman
excellent jlp
grilling uh thank you let's just pick
another random moment from the jessie
lee peterson interview and check in on
it let's go
i don't know like how about right here
let's see you of that is is that am i
sort of on to the the
the ideology here well i have not
perverted it even though this is
actually
funny let me back up that what you said
all women who have not grown up
close to their fathers have uh
illogical mindset they're up and down in
the way they think and feel
and they're controlled by the darkness
of their imagination
likewise males males who have not
overcome their mothers and returned to
their fathers
they have illogical mindsets just like
their mother and just like women
so it's almost like you've you've almost
taken
a a bit of a freudian approach and
like perverted it into sort of like your
your your
christian view of that is is that am i
sort of on to the
the ideology here well i have not
perverted it even god said that we must
be born again
you were born of the woman and anyone
who's born of the woman
is dying but those who are born of the
spirit
of god are living and so i didn't make
that up god did that
you have to call him fraudulent or
whatever phrase this
is the word i used of course was
freudian not fraudulent but i don't know
if jesse is familiar with the freudian
ideology oh trump's life
anywhere hold on a second here we go and
your
loved ones and we will do it rapidly
and it's in very good order and some of
it has already been implemented
in short we're delivering better care
with more choice
at a much lower cost and working to
ensure americans have
access to the care they need my plan
expands affordable insurance options
reduces the cost of prescription drugs
will end surprise medical billing
increases fairness through
price transparency streamlines
bureaucracy accelerates innovation
strongly protects medicare and always
protects patients with pre-existing
conditions
anybody believe that
by contrast the democrat party is
pushing a socialist nightmare
their plans will result in rationing
care
denying choice putting americans on
waitlists
driving the best doctors out of medicine
permanently
and delaying life-saving cures
over life-saving there we go
over 130 democrats in congress including
senator harris
have endorsed legislation to outlaw the
private health plans of 180 million
americans
on top of it all former vice president
joe biden promised to give free federal
health care to anyone in the world who
illegally crosses our border
his plan to provide government health
care to illegal immigrants would
bankrupt our health care system
collapse our hospitals and destroy
medicare
while bringing millions and millions of
people
lured into our country lured
as long as i am president we will
safeguard our borders
and our seniors we're pleased to be
joined today by secretary
of health and human services done a
great job alex azar
toxic guys thank you
and very importantly cms administrator
seema
verma thank you seymour oh not not fema
he's the worst
a great friend of mine and a great
friend of healthcare frankly
senator bill cassidy phil
representatives michael burgess and greg
murphy so instrumental thank you thank
you thanks
and many many state and local officials
are here with us thank you very much
since the plague arrived from china we
have seen our doctors nurses first
responders scientists and researchers at
their very best
we slashed red tape to accelerate the
development of life-saving treatments
reducing the fatality rate by 85 percent
since april
incredible overall europe has seen an
almost 50 percent
greater excess mortality rate than that
of the united states
and despite europe's punishing lockdowns
they are now seeing a huge surge
very sadly in cases under operation warp
speed my administration is developing a
vaccine in record time
it will be distributed before the end of
the year and maybe quite a bit sooner
than that
four vaccines are now in the final stage
of clinical trials
it just about at the end a lot of things
are looking very good
it is the most ambitious vaccine program
in us history probably in any history
the vaccines are being mass produced in
advance
so they can be delivered within 24 hours
of approval
the vaccine will be safe and it will be
effective
it will defeat the virus and it will end
the pandemic
the economy will surge to record highs
you see what's happening with the
numbers that are coming out
records all normal life all of this is
lies i'd have to interject
we did we did it we got the 50 000
followers on twitch i love it thank you
the history of our country from an
economic and hopefully in many other
ways
when i was elected i inherited a thing
called
obamacare has anybody heard of obamacare
it was terrible that's the way i feel
too
it was terrible and very very expensive
hurt a lot of people premiums were too
high
deductibles were premiums were too high
so trump ended the individual mandate
which kept them from being even higher
but by far the worst part of obamacare
was
this thing called the individual mandate
he has no idea part of our largest ever
tax cut in the history of the united
states
we put in a provision to kill this worst
provision of obamacare the individual
mandate
it was a disaster and it was really the
essence
of obamacare it made you pay a
tremendous amount of money in order to
not have to pay
for health insurance think of that you
had to pay a fortune
in order not
it was really terrible and so unfair to
so many destroyed families
we were able to terminate the subtitles
weirdly said you had to pee a fortune
rather than pay a fortune that's weird
existing conditions that would not have
been
that particular law would never have
been signed if it were otherwise
obamacare is no longer obamacare
as we worked on it and managed it very
well we stabilized it
got premiums down very substantially
that was alex and that was sema and you
did a fantastic job
but it's still unacceptable to me
because it's too expensive
and doesn't really do the job as well as
we could have
so what we have now is a much better
plan
it is no longer obamacare because we've
gotten rid of the worst part of it the
individual mandate
and made it much less expensive a lot of
that was through
good management we manage it properly
we have tremendous people working on it
simultaneously with all of this
we are joining in a lawsuit to end this
ill-conceived plan
i'm in court to terminate this really
really
terrible situation if we win we will
have a better and less expensive plan
that will always protect individuals
with pre-existing conditions
when will he tell us the plan the
original
the original version obamacare by far
much better much better again we will
always
protect patients with pre-existing
conditions so today i'm
laying out my vision for the future of
american health care
he was supposed to sign the new plan
into law six weeks ago now he's just
laying out the vision what's going on
full strength the first health care plan
will be a core part of our national
renewal in a few moments i'll sign an
executive order outlining the three
pillars of my plan
and directing my administration to
implement these
critical reforms executive orders are
not health care
plans folks more choice more
choice for the american patients
the last administration severely
restricted consumer choice through the
greatest health care lie ever told
if you like your plan you can keep your
plan
if you like your doctor you can keep
your doctor
you remember that 28 times that was
stated by our president but it turned
out not to be true
when i took office more than 50 percent
of
counties nationwide offered plans from
only a single insurance company
on the individual market starting next
month more than 90 percent of the
counties will have multiple options to
choose from which is really some
difference
understand that this was not actually
really the problem of obamacare
it was more the problem of the places
that didn't expand medicaid or do the
exchanges
right for you and your family these
options include new affordable choices
that cost
up to 60 percent less than obamacare
think of that 60 percent less
for example we're opening up short-term
plans that are much cheaper than
obamacare
that can be customized to your
individual needs
we're also offering association health
plans that allow small businesses to
pull together and offer more affordable
policies
that's a good idea these are tremendous
options implementation
exists before we came into office and
through a massive expansion of health
reimbursement arrangements millions of
americans will be able to shop for a
plan of their choice on the individual
market
and then have their employer cover the
full cost
furthermore i'll work to make individual
health care premiums
fully tax deductible that will be a big
difference
i think health care premiums if you're
paying out of pocket either way it
should be tax deductible i
i believe i don't think trump can
actually get that uh done working
patients back in charge and we're
putting
them first my plan will also
revolutionize
access to telehealth that's something
that really has taken off
uh during the pandemic it's taken off
like a rocket show
it's increased close to nine thousand
percent over nine thousand nobody was
using it and when we had the pandemic
they started using it then they started
really liking it then it started getting
better and better
bill now it's up to nine thousand
percent who would think that right
one of the few things that we got from
this
disaster that came from china
when we rapidly expanded its
availability for medicare beneficiaries
during the
pandemic the number of telehealth
users increased so incredibly to 14
000 a week it was 1.7
million it was increasing at levels that
nobody's ever seen before
just about any kind of a program this is
the future of
health care we will ensure all americans
have the freedom to consult with doctors
from the safety and convenience of their
homes
the second pillar of my plan is lower
costs for
families and seniors lower cost
for years patients have been shocked to
receive
unexpected bills for thousands of
dollars this is one of those things
where like
any time the left says hey let's pay for
something through taxes they go
they're just handing out free stuff and
then trump
as a pillar says one of the things we're
going to do is lower costs and people
clap
but how are you how are you going to do
it that's that's not that's not action
hey we're lowering cost okay
transparency
and trace transparency is great for the
great doctors the good doctors and it's
also great for the
great and good hospitals that's where
it's really fantastic for them to in
addition obviously to the patients
for the first time ever we will create
true competition in healthcare
both hospitals and insurance companies
will be required to post all of their
prices online
this transformative policy will allow
you to see your exact out-of-pocket
costs before you go
for treatment making it easy to shop for
the best price
costs will come way down some people
think this will have a
bigger impact i really hope people
understand that a ton of this stuff
nothing happens when you sign an
executive order trump can sign an
executive order
then you have to create the
infrastructure just like if you work
through the legislative process and so
none of this stuff without a doubt
none of this will happen before january
20th for sure
if at all i really need people to
understand that
and you know that we talk about it all
the time
congress they come over we've been
talking about it for a long time they've
been talking about it for years they
know the problem but we've been
subsidizing socialist nations and others
by paying the highest drug prices in the
world by far
and yet we're the largest purchaser of
prescription drugs by
far and this is all while countries got
away with paying
so much less so much less incredibly
less
under my plan we will pay the exact same
price as other countries that's at the
lowest level
so we will be matching remember that
that's up to other people
to okay and to make a deal with you
can't just say
this is what we're going to pay and then
it happens this is this is delusional
a little bit but you'll get discounts of
40 50 60 80
90 who knows percent numbers that you
wouldn't
believe and we were the only ones
in 52 years to bring drug prices down
the last year they went down as you know
but that was before this they went down
just a little bit but just a little bit
was the only time in 52
years now they're going to go down
massively favored nations this will lead
to
a very large savings for american
families and plummeting drug prices they
will plummet
the obama biden administration cave to
big pharma and allowed drug prices to
explode
the only bad part about this transaction
is that they are advertising like crazy
make sure you don't elect trump and all
it means is that your drug prices are
coming down so it's
it's incredible they have unlimited
money for ads but they're taking ads and
every time you see an ad
just think that your drug prices are
coming down i now understand why other
politicians wouldn't do it
because it was a very easy thing to do
but it took a certain amount of courage
i will say
that
all right
so it means that i'm taking on big
pharma like now everybody
this is a combination of stuff you can't
do through executive order
combined with lies combined with
delusions
so if germany's paying 10 cents for a
bill and we're paying two and a half
dollars for the same exact bill from the
same place
oh not the same plan same genius
scientists same everything
same laboratory we get the same price as
they do
you're talking about numbers that are
unthinkable
favored nations flows so it's really
something
and they're attacking me viciously we
know that and
uh they're attacking me really because
i'm fighting for you but it's worth the
fight it's worth the fight i think
and i just i can say this i think i
don't think it's confidential uh
our chief of staff is here mark meadows
from
a very great state known as north
carolina
that happens to come from north carolina
it's good stuff he wanted to be here for
that reason probably more than
even listening to this because you've
heard it but mark will tell you that big
pharma is calling and negotiating and
negotiating and they want to make a deal
and there's a deal somewhere but it's uh
it's something that's taking place right
now so they're negotiating but
this is where we are and they're
negotiating for one reason before that
they wouldn't even think about
negotiating with any
other administration they would uh they
cannot believe this is actually
happening
and if we can't make a deal we will but
mark you're negotiating
literally as we speak right negotiating
he doesn't make a great deal we'll blame
north carolina okay so that's great now
mark is a real pro at this understands
it
complicated business uh but he
understands it very well today my
administration's taking action
on every piece of the executive order i
signed on
prescription drug importation in july
the american people pay an average of
over listen to this
three times more for medicine than
canadians
so you could be two feet away on each
side of the border
three times more and that's the way it
is
canada is far more than many other
countries
my plan will allow states wholesalers
and pharmacies to do something
career politicians have promised for
decades because it was very simple as an
idea
but never delivered we will finally
allow the safe for all the criticism of
biden's teleprompter use trump literally
can
barely look away from the prompter he
just is locked into that thing huh
so this means a state or whatever can go
to canada and buy your
drugs for a fraction of the price that
they're charging right now
massive numbers of tremendous numbers
florida wants to do it colorado wants to
do it many states want to do it
and they will be doing it but that's
still higher than the favored nations
so as favored nations kicks in i think
that probably beats everybody no matter
where you are no matter where you're
trying to buy this will be
a game changer for american seniors and
by allowing you to do this through
canada
we're doing it very very quickly so it
goes very fast
and the new rule goes into effect as of
today is that fast enough i think so
what do you think
a congressman what that
the america first healthcare plan
includes another historic provision to
benefit our great seniors
under my plan 33 million medicare
beneficiaries will soon receive
a card in the mail containing 200
that they can use to help pay for
prescription drugs nobody's seen this
before these cards are incredible the
cards will be mailed out
in coming weeks i will always take care
of our wonderful senior citizens
you know uh i i don't beggars can't be
choosers right but
a two hundred dollar card is not really
going to solve
the systemic problem that we have here
we're going to be saving with
the favored nations and various other
things that we've done
we've approved more affordable generic
drugs than any administration in history
i had no idea but i had had many
doctors who have great respect for by
the way come to me and
i said well what's the difference
between this and this one is a very
well-known name
one is just a pill and a bottle with
no tag on it and they said zero i said
let's go in a little bit better right
the name zero
and yet the name brand will cost five
and even ten times more money than the
generic so yeah
imagine only learning this in your 70s
that generic brands
are the same but they are generic
the benefits of government discounts on
insulin
and the epipen insulin and that you know
that is a big
uh that is a big deal that is a big deal
insulin is one of the most common
medicines for cinnamon
epipen yeah
and this is something that uh sema
worked on so hard
insulin prices soared under the last
administration
like you wouldn't believe right seymour
under my plan hundreds of thousands of
medicare patients will see their insulin
costs capped
at just 35 a month that's a 66
percent cost reduction
and this feature will be well available
1 600 medicare plans that seniors can
begin signing up for starting october
1st and
under certain circumstances seymour it's
literally
almost free this uh insulin which
they were just ripping you on they'll
pay you to take it
free even lower than the 35 a month so
you did a fantastic job in that thank
you very much
this is like there's actually business
subcultures where we're talking like
this is considered leadership
and uh it's just what a weird country we
live in without it they just couldn't
afford it now they can definitely afford
it
we'll accelerate our relentless effort
to save seniors money on their premiums
since i took office we reduced medicare
part d premiums by 12 percent
medicare advantage premiums are also
down dramatically a 44
reduction in north carolina that's good
43 lower in pennsylvania
and a 54 lower price in michigan
so that's something and we have them all
over the country
all over the country there are numbers
just like that will
ensure that all seniors pay the same
price for the same service whether at a
hospital
a surgery center or a doctor's office
this will save seniors billions and
billions of dollars a year we're talking
about the billions
and it also saves our government a lot
of money but we'll save our seniors
everybody billions of dollars a year
fantastic job
we're putting into place the largest
package of saving for
seniors of any administration in history
no administration is even close to what
we've done and i've said it
having to do much more than even health
care there's no administration
in its first three and a half years
that's done anywhere close to the things
we've done
and i never even get criticized for
saying it that must mean it's true
right my congressman and my great
senator
wow under the democrat plan
costs will skyrocket our seniors will
lose the benefits they paid into their
entire by the way it's like what plan is
he talking about when he says the
democrat plan is he talking about
biden's campaign
platform like what what is he actually
talking about i mean we're just helping
other countries countries that
aren't even friends of ours but we help
our friends and we help
socialism all over the world and we hurt
our people and we're not doing that any
longer socialism
as long as i'm president
no one will lay a hand on your medicare
your medicare is going to be safe and
it's going to be solid
remember the white house budget proposed
cutting funding
the final pillar of america first
healthcare plan is
better care that's better care for
american patients
historic action i'm taking today
includes the first ever executive order
to affirm it is the official policy of
the united states government to protect
patients with
pre-existing conditions so we're making
that official
we're putting it down in a stand because
our opponents the democrats like to
constantly talk about it and yet
pre-existing conditions are much safer
with us than they are
with them and now we have it affirmed
this is a firm signed and done
so we can put that to rest they'll say
it anyway because it's disinformation
disinformation same thing goes for
social security remember during the last
campaign four years ago they kept saying
i was going to
destroy social security i made social
security stronger better
they will be the ones that destroy
social security because they're going to
destroy our country
they will destroy our economy he
literally proposed cutting half of the
funding to social security with the
payroll tax stuff
remember he is going to immediately
attack now just the opposite
your social security is 100 with me but
it's not
a hundred percent with them any
healthcare reform legislation that comes
to my desk from congress must protect
the pre-existing conditions or i won't
sign it and i made that pledge and i
made that pledge
last week but now i'm making it in
writing we're putting it down and we
have it signed and we have us here
the new democrat lie is that they will
cover pre-existing conditions but
they're covered now let's take over
economic shutdowns that they talk about
if you look at
this state frankly where you have
democrat governors democrat leaders
those sta those states are in very very
bad
what's he talking about obamacare
requires
the coverage of pre-existing conditions
and that's not changed what does he mean
democrats wouldn't cover it democrats
are the ones who passed it federal judge
ruled it unconstitutional what they were
doing they're hurting people
there's damage on the other side of a
shutdown people don't realize with
suicides and
drug use and all of the alcohol
it's a terrible thing that happens and
michigan's another state the shutdown is
very severe
by the way on november 4th i'm sure
everything will be opened they'll
announce on the evening
of november 3rd that we're opening up
unless these unsolicited ballots don't
come in for weeks and weeks and there it
is
you know they want them to come in over
a long period of time it's going to be a
very interesting day
november 3rd it's going to be a very
interesting day and coverage for
illegal immigrants will collapse our
economy will collapse under their system
and
make your health care system totally
insolvent
you know that as great doctors and
people that do this you know that what
they're doing is
socialized medicine and it's not
acceptable it's going to be a disaster
in terms of quality and cost it'll ruin
our country
under their plan you'll lose your doctor
again and you will lose your coverage
you will lose everything having to do
with what we're talking about on my
watch i will never let the radical left
take away your health care you'll always
you're not trying to
you're not the left is trying to expand
health care
the america first health care plan will
deliver another long-awaited reform we
will put
you in control of your own medical
records
we'll require doctors to make your
records available electronically
and you alone them and you'll control
them and they will be portable
and you'll be able to work seamlessly
with all of your
medical providers it'll make your life a
lot easier okay
much much easier seems like a previous
administration
led by sleepy joe biden spent 35 billion
dollars and failed to get it done you
know that 35 billion
dollars where they failed we are
delivering to give
critically ill patients access to
life-saving treatment
i also signed right to try you know what
right to try is i'm very
quick to me the whole one knows it right
to try is
is so great it's so great and what i
think i'd like to do i'll do it really
quickly
i'm going to run through just a quick
list of
accomplishments that we've done and you
know
we've really become the healthcare
party the republican party and nobody
knows that
the news doesn't talk about it
but i'm going to just say i mean it's a
list of things oh my god he's got two
pages
and it'll go quickly but i just thought
i'd take it out i said you know i'd like
to read that to the audience of
course today and this is just a partial
list
oh god we repealed the individual
mandate that's bad
eliminated obamacare's health insurance
medical device and the cadillac taxes
that's a big deal
nobody knows people forget all of this
they say i wonder who did that
could it have been no joe biden he
doesn't know what it is
expanded association health plans
increased availability of short-term
limited duration plans
imagine being so deluded that you think
clapping for this
is some form of activism never mind
being in the room
and you will see them at a level that
you will never
you'll never see this again they will go
down so low
and as i said we had the largest annual
decrease we had the only decrease over a
52-year period
more generic prescriptions approved
savings america is saving america an
estimated
2.6 billion dollars in the first 18
months of
the administration alone so in 18 months
we saved 2.6 billion with
generic drugs signed four executive
orders to lower prescription drug prices
signed legislation banning pharmacy gag
clauses
does that make sense to you no
i mean what what people were under what
even the pharmacist who had to do it's
weird he seems to be listing his past
accomplishments some of the things he
claims to be doing today which he of
course never did at all
transparency in healthcare that'll be
one of the biggest things and most
people have no idea what it means
yeah this seems to be the first time
trump has seen this list some people
said that's bigger than health care
required hospitals to post standard
prices on the internet
modernize and strengthen medicare with
more options more benefits and lower
premiums substantially
improve kidney care such a big deal with
more transplants and better treatment
kidney care is so tough for people with
a problem people with
a problem very substantially lowered the
price of insulin as we said for our
seniors
invested in advances in generic therapy
for
sickle cell disease hey by the way guys
a huge shout out to jaby gatz
uh one of our moderators on twitch there
was like a toxic comment that came in
that was bandworthy
jabby gatz had this person banned i
think it was a third of a second
i think that it was insane it was faster
than the speed of light
he uh really went very very strong on
drug demand and the opioid crisis with
expanded access to
medication-assisted treatment and
life-saving
naloxone
most people call it naloxone but trump
calls it nalaxone
over 35 percent so if you look at
the opioid obviously horror show
it decreased by over 35 since january of
2017. we've worked very very hard on
that
launched findtreatment.gov to connect
those with
substance abuse disorder to treatment we
have an incredible situation
spinetreatment.gov
past right to try to give critically ill
patients
access to life-saving cures where it
hasn't been approved yet
by the fda incredible
and and by the way many trump has no
clue what is on this list some
examples on right to try that have been
amazing
launched an initiative to end aids hiv
aids
in america we think in six years it will
be
largely eradicated who would have ever
thought and this could have started two
years before i got there but they chose
not to do it but we have and we've
launched the initiative actually been
going on projects
into its almost fourth year and
at the time we did it it was going to be
10 years at the end of 10 years now six
years we're already down to
okay wait it was going to be ten years
at the end of ten now it's six could
have been done two ago
hiv aids and i need a calculator it's
incredible when i first heard about it
when i first heard about it i said why
wouldn't they have started it early but
they didn't
expanded access to telehealth especially
in rural
and underserved areas telehealth signed
historic va
choice legislation
obama signed that in 2014 it has nothing
to do with trump
the real choice not the weak choice the
very very weak the choice that didn't
mean anything
but it's been a tremendous success and
we just got a 91
approval rating from our vets the
highest we've ever had by
by a lot
and we also well we're at it we signed
accountability va accountability that's
where people don't love our vets if they
don't take care of our vets
you must love the vets that's what trump
said they'd have to live
in hell with these vets with uh with the
people that we're supposed to be taking
care of and
we have a thing called va accountability
they're accountable now
if they don't treat our vets great if
they don't take care of our vets if they
don't love our vets
they live in hell we can fire them we
can say you're fired
feels like another lifetime that trump
was known for you're fired now he's
known for plasma and injecting bleach
veteran suicide had launched the 24-hour
veteran hotline for
suicide and it's really working
that's a good thing and signed the
largest ever increase in child care
development block grants
those are just those are just some of
the uh
those are some of the things that we've
done we've done actually a lot more than
that but
we have to get back to business here
right those are things that we've done
and nobody has any idea when you look at
a list like that
in people's defense that's the first
time trump ever saw most of those things
too
socialist agenda an avalanche of
regulation would extinguish the flame of
excellence that makes america the center
of scientific discovery groundbreaking
treatment
and life-saving cures in our all-out war
against the virus we've lifted
bureaucratic barriers and marshaled
america's scientific industrial and
technical brilliance and we do have
total brilliance some of it's in this
room by the way in case you don't know
i will apply as really as some of the
people right great bill
some incredible people in this room i'll
apply the same
determination to accelerate medical
breakthroughs
in all areas including for alzheimer's
diabetes
generic treatments for sickle cell
disease early detection of cancer and
people wondering trump's been going
about 35 minutes americans with kidney
disease we enable patients to receive
at-home dialysis and we're investing in
the creation of
an artificial kidney we're getting very
close and we introduce critical
incentives to make more kidneys
available for
transplant a change that will save tens
of thousands of lives what people have
to go through with
kidney disease is incredible it's
incredible
they work so hard i said how do they do
they can live
a long life but it's so much work to do
it that they literally one doctor told
me that
they die of hard work it's such a job
to go and i guess dialysis et cetera
it's such a hard job that they die of
of literally they die of just hard work
trump's not going to die of hard work
that we can be pretty sure of and what
we're doing and
especially with some of the research
that's been done what we're coming up
with you'll be seeing it
very soon i believe as we invest in the
future we will permanently bring our
medical supply chains back home
that was an applause line guys
[Music]
we will produce our medical supplies
pharmaceuticals and treatments right
here in the united states right here in
north carolina
we're going to bring a lot of business
to if you remember puerto rico used to
do it and then they
brought tax legislation that destroyed
that whole thing they all left but they
were very happy in puerto rico we're
going to bring it back to puerto rico
and
many of our states that uh that we'll be
doing it and north carolina i see is on
the list as being a very top one so
we're going to bring it back to north
carolina and the country
and we'll reverse the disastrous and
heartless decision joe biden made in
1996 to shut down the pharmaceutical
industry
he's running against a uh a version of
joe biden
from 96 look at the things trump was
saying in 96 if this election is taking
place in 96.
we're doing a fantastic job and one day
it was just literally gone biden shut it
down with what he did with taxes and
it was uh it was a disgrace but we will
bring it back
okay under our leadership american
medicine will make the biggest
breakthroughs the largest leaps the most
exciting strides
and the most outstanding discoveries
before i sign a historic executive order
implementing this ambitious agenda let
me introduce two americans great
americans who will benefit from
our policies julia strathopolis
freeman sheldon syndrome with with the
freeman
sheldon syndrome which is tough an
extremely rare muscle and
bone disorder when the previous
administration
julia's family saw their premiums with
sensitivity individual markets
skyrocketed to
3 000 a month and more
her parents had to go without a health
insurance just to afford coverage for
their children
since i was elected their families
premiums have been slashed by
more than 40 percent and what i am
seeing people notice that trump's neck
and face
are they could not be more different
colors it is really bizarre and i know
that it's sort of
you know it's borderline but it really
goes to his bizarre
uh a set how he assesses things he
thinks this
i guess is better than the alternative
it's whacked
you look great julia thank you that's
great thank you julia
it's a great story but we're inspired by
your courage thank you very much
also with us is sharon leader a
financial planner from nearby concord
after spending less than 24 hours in the
hospital and receiving a few basic tests
she received surprise bills that added
up to four
thousand dollars that's a lot of money
despite having insurance sharon
those days will soon be over because
we'll end surprise medical building once
and for all
no more buildings any surprise medical
buildings will not be built
that's why they call it surprise
buildings you got home and she was
surprised
they sent you the bill you opened it up
you thought it was going to be 25
and it was a little more than that right
that's great well we're taking care of
it thank you very much here
we're standing up for our people
we're standing up to special interests
that's interesting
i see the super chat from candyman do
you guys think that trump is so low
energy because he was demoralized by
getting booed out of the ginsburg
memorial that's interesting
socialism or below it if you want to
call it that way
but we are standing up to both whichever
one you want to choose
and we are fighting for the incredible
people of north carolina
incredible people people i love i love
the people
we named as you know my grandchild is
named carolina so
loves the people
[Applause]
beautiful carolina my most beautiful
child
but we're providing better care and more
choice at a
lower cost substantially lower cost
we're delivering a healthier safer
brighter and more prosperous future for
every citizen
in our magnificent land because we are
proudly putting america first that
hasn't happened for a long time
okay
on behalf of all americans i will now
sign
the executive order i want to thank you
all for being here god bless you
god bless north carolina and god bless
america thank you very much
[Applause]
what is that book by the way hi julia
once again ladies and gentlemen
completely beyond parody impossible to
satire
putting comedy writers the world over
out of work
because you can't possibly satirize it
the curb your enthusiasm theme should be
playing yes
it should be playing
and there it is
there it is ladies and gentlemen
various elements of medical on stage
with donald trump
oh dropping pens and sharpies
thank you very much everybody
[Music]
that's playing over a speaker right they
don't have a band there do they
trump will wander around now
maybe sign some pieces of paper that
people could sell for
10 grand or maybe 20 bucks
here sell this hat for 30 grand sir it's
worth 90.
the girl giving trump a bracelet but
trump's a germaphobe he's gonna just
hold it in his left hand and throw it in
the trash as soon as possible
not putting it on as you can see
man this is embarrassing
it's also sort of uncommon that no one's
pulling trump off rarely is a president
just allowed to kind of hang
with nobody right up on him moving him
away from people
[Music]
now we got to bring up the oboes now
need more trumpet
[Music]
and there's the fist pump ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much thank you
very much
[Music]
watching trump wander around is
strangely zen-like
i mean when he's not talking everybody
feels so much better that i think it
does help my mood
[Music]
there he is trump going with the full
seat uh
suit not a particularly modern look but
certainly probably better for trump's
physique if nothing else
and now he should wander off if he can
find the exit between the flags
[Music]
and there he goes uh and it is over
ladies and gentlemen we survive you'll
be survived congratulations
all right everybody tuesday tuesday as
they say on tradio
um we will have a very very powerful
stream the first debate between uh
donald trump and joseph r biden jr
it is going to be wild oh douglas murray
was recently on with rogan his publicist
pitched him to me and i said yeah i'll
talk to douglas
i'll talk to douglas i'm interested in
that uh so we've got that
scaramucci joining me very very soon
um going to talk to scaramucci we are in
touch with the biden campaign hey listen
to this by the way guys hold on a second
i actually have an exciting bit of news
um
where is this list youtube has reached
out to me
because the biden campaign reached out
to youtube listen to this this is
actually exciting
um we would like for you to virtually
sit down with surrogates of joe biden
such as senator elizabeth warren
senator kirsten gillibrand congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez
congresswoman ayanna presley who i know
already
and simone sanders who follows me on
um i think it's on twitter
that she follows me so i went back and i
said give me all five
we will take all five absolutely um so
we're we're
looking into that and i think honestly i
have to tell you guys
if i'm completely completely honest with
you
i think that now that we've surpassed a
million and we are
you know of the sort of daily
progressive news shows
at a million it's tyt and us um
i think it's good for credibility
because now i mean listen we we've had
when we had elizabeth warren on we had
to go crazy trying to get her
she's being pitched to us now as well as
aoc and others now whether we can
actually get it all booked
you know that's uh that's a different
question and if it doesn't happen we're
gonna
exclusively blame producer pat but
anyway
we could have potentially all five of
them plus the mooch scaramucci
um in just the five and a half weeks
which will just be five weeks by next
week
left before the election so thank you to
everybody for joining me get those
memberships at joinpakman.com
make sure you hit that subscribe button
on youtube we are at almost
1.02 million subscribers
and we have breached 50 000 followers on
twitch
which uh has has gotten us deserving
to be played out with convalescent
plasma i'll see everybody very very
soon
i'm pleased to make a truly historic
announcement in our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
[Music]
battling a current infection
convalescent
[Music]
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million to fund the mayo
clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescent
[Music]
convalescence